[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they bring in mark stein new york times
nba
writer uh mark what was the moment where
you went
what or who last night yeah i think
mcglovin should know more of those names
those all should not be shocking to him
but
uh jalen smith at 10 for sure i mean
that allowed halliburton to slip
and that was that was definitely a
surprise but but the
williams going at four that that was
bubbling
that was bubbling well in advance of the
draft actually starting last night but
it's also indicative of what kind of
draft this was
i mean you had minnesota and golden
state
really looking hard to find trade down
to get more win you know
win now type of players and they
couldn't find those trades so
number four probably is a good spot to
to to take a risk on a guy with a lot of
upside like williams who like you
as you said he didn't didn't start at
all in college
but the bulls and a lot of teams think
that he has the upside that that
justifies
him there but it was a weird night i
don't want to be
i don't want to be so down beat about it
but
when you get that klay thompson news
right before the fact i mean that
that it's already a virtual draft which
is just i mean as as well as you can do
broadcast wise it's just not going to be
nearly the same so it's already
the weirdest draft we've ever seen and
then to get that kind of news was
that shook the league and not in a good
way do we have an update on klay
thompson and can you set the scene where
he was playing this pickup game who he
was playing with
well we'll get the update the firm
update today but all the rumbles coming
out are
are you know concern of the highest
degree i mean he was
he was basically playing a pickup game
in downtown l.a and
and guys are looking for those kind of
games right now because
let's face it the season is upon us
it's upon guys a lot faster than they
expected
you know in the bubble the word was hey
the season might start
might not start until february might not
even start until march and now
it's starting before christmas and klay
thompson has been out a long time
and he was playing pickup ball and it's
just it's
i mean you saw the reaction of fellow
pros last night
he is so well respected and so well
liked
and you know guys on other teams are
taking it as a crushing
blow to hear how serious this injury
could be we don't have the full
confirmation but
obviously it doesn't sound good i
wondered if golden state was going to
alter their draft strategy when they got
the uh
the news about klay thompson do you know
if there was any thought of
maybe changing up and not taking james
wiseman
well bob myers did acknowledge that they
thought about it for a second but look
it it happened way too late and let's be
honest in the modern draft
who who are you going to find that can
plug in next season to even come
close to replicating what klay thompson
does it's impossible
well i was thinking that i put steph as
the off guard and i have lamello ball
running my point
now no i mean because you can't
i mean you can't make that dramatic of a
decision in a matter
of hours i think the warriors should be
absolutely right they need size
they need athleticism wiseman is who
they wanted if they kept the pick
that's the way it materialized and and
you know i do think we have to remember
this is this is the state of the nba
draft
at this point you know if if three or
four rookies make a real impact next
season that's a lot like you
you i i don't think you can react to an
injury in in real time like that
and change course the top draft prospect
number one pick anthony edwards
kind of uh shook things up a little bit
when he said he would prefer to
be drafted in the nfl i don't did this
change anybody's opinion of anthony
edwards and his desire to want to be a
great nba player
i think it changed a lot of opinions in
the punditry and has a lot of people
scratching their heads and certainly
something he's going to be asked about
and be asked to
explain as his nba career unfold but
it didn't dissuade minnesota and the
wolves
the wolves were in a tough spot this was
a draft with no
no one that seems considered a franchise
cornerstone not like what we were
looking at
a year ago when you got zion williamson
and john barat at the top of the draft
and
those teams are just so thrilled to get
their guy
you know positionally edwards fits the
best
of the players who were at the top of
this draft but
i mean there are there are question
marks about them so you know minnesota
tried everything it could to construct a
deal trade down
see if they can get someone who they
considered you know more along the
timeline of carl anthony towns and
deangelo russell who
it's time for those guys to win they
couldn't find it but look they did make
the trade
to bring back ricky rubio and rubio had
a really good season in phoenix phoenix
was happy with ricky rubio but obviously
you get the chance to trade for chris
paul
you're going to do that but so minnesota
made the move to bring rubio back
let's you know let's see how how he and
russell
fit together but uh yeah i
i i was i would i was not envious of
minnesota's position having to pick
number one out of this group
i loved what philadelphia did last night
i don't know if it's
a draft strategy but it's just
basketball roster strategy
recap what they did mark what it is
well daryl moore i mean that was that
was the other pre-draft thunderbolt that
daryl mori found a way to move al
horford
which before the the sixers hired daryl
mori you would have found
very few people around the league saying
and thinking
that philadelphia was going to be able
to trade him and
daryl mori comes in he moves al horford
he brings
he gets he gets danny green in that
trade with the thunder
later on they bring in a shooter in seth
curry
they send josh richardson to dallas seth
curry
has been you know a fantastic shooter
fantastic value on the contract he has
and just even more than the moves to me
it's just if you're a sixer fan and
you've
it's just been nothing but chaos and
turmoil for years and you have all this
doubt about how embiid and simmons fit
but
daryl mori in very short order i mean
he's been there a matter of days he's
just shown an ability you know he
he makes moves he gets things done he's
decisive
i think it just sends the signal that
yeah we want this guy running our team
he
you know they're not they're by no means
done but they made moves that make a lot
more sense for their roster and
i mean the east is the east has gotten
tougher still
nowhere near the depths of the west but
philly looking a lot better on paper
today to go with
your milwaukee's your boston's your
toronto's your miami's
brooklyn's coming back now the top of
the east just looks so much
better talking to mark stein who covers
the nba for the new york times
i'll leave you with this anything
happened last night that would
move the harden russell westbrook
conversation
forward no well
yes actually one not in a forward way
i reported the day before the draft that
charlotte's appetite to trade for
russell westbrook would go up if they
didn't get lamello ball and
they got lamela ball so that presumably
takes
charlotte out of the mix as a potential
landing spot
for russell westbrook so you know the
knicks
have explored it but it's it's really
conditional
interest the knicks would only do that
deal under certain circumstances if
they're giving up just the minimum
amount
of trade assets and houston gave up so
much to get westbrook
they're not just going to trade him to
make a trade you know washington that
was another one
john wall and russell westbrook are a
salary match but the rockets are trying
to get something
they're trying to get at least one
future first back or a good young player
they're
you know russell westbrook was averaging
27 8 and 7 at his peak last season
before he had all the
injury and coronavirus problems in the
bubble he did play very well
in the second half of the season the
rockets don't want to just
move him for the sake of it and in terms
of harden the consistent message
coming out of houston is they are not in
a rush they want to try to fix this
thing
they're not just going to trade him to
the nets they don't have to trade him to
the nets
just because that's where hardin wants
to go they've got him under contract
for two more years i don't think you're
going to see the rockets
rush into a hardened deal at all they
are going to try to slow this thing down
and see if they can put the pieces back
together
thank you mark we appreciate you getting
up to join us we appreciate your time
all good see you guys thank you but mark
stein covers the nba for the new york
times